si on veut planter davantage d'avoir
davantage de verdissement dans nos
villes des infos qui est un espace au
verdissement puis l'espace délimité en
ville donc aux balles gagnées sur la
sarthe
[Musique]
à
pourquoi autant d'aspects dans nos
villes sont on remonte un peu dans le
passé on a un développement des villes
qui est beaucoup centré sur le tout à
l'auto a donc on a asphalté pour se
déplacer des rues des boulevards de plus
en plus large on a aussi des maires de
stationnement beaucoup d espaces
asphaltés donc quand elles placent volt
en grandes quantités dans nos villes et
tous posé la question estime nécessaire
que ça
mais nos villes en général sont
minéralisés de 75 même des fois jusqu'à
100 pour sa d'un site les trottoirs les
rues les stationnements donc recouvert
d'asphalt ou de surfaces qui sont
imperméables comme du béton donc on met
une couche finalement sur les sols
naturels dans nos villes
[Musique]
la déminéralisation bien tout simplement
c'est se libérer de la salle donc se
retirer l'asphalté retour et les
surfaces artificielles des sols par
exemple on a un stationnement d'un
heureux et c'est de l'enlever et faire
d'autres choses finalement de la
plantation du verdissement donc remettre
finalement la nature en ville
[Musique]
avec la question des changements
climatiques et les événements de
précipitation donc de pluie peut être
pas plus courant est aussi plus intense
donc plus d'eau plus souvent donc de
déminéralisée ce que ça permet ce que ça
donne aux soldes la capacité de jouer
son rôle d'épongé permet de ralentir le
parcours de l'eau vers les
infrastructures par les égouts de
diminuer la pression sur nos
infrastructures un effet bien connu
aussi l'avoir trop d'aspects de danville
c'est toute la question des effets des
îlots de chaleur à la salle absorbent la
chaleur entre un espace asphalte et puis
un espace verdi et peut y avoir jusqu'à
12 degrés différents c'est pas banal et
ça ça a des impacts sur la santé surtout
dans le contexte des changements
climatiques où il ya de plus en plus des
vagues de chaleur de canicule
[Musique]
allez beaucoup de citoyens qui décident
de se libérer de la soirée puis à
différentes échelles il ya des citoyens
que je devais pourquoi j'espère très
haute à mon terrain pourquoi est ce que
j'aurai de la salle pour ma place de
stationnement je pourrais me des pavés
alvéolé par exemple d'autres vont plus
loin aussi dit j'ai pas besoin de deux
cases de stationnement sur mon terrain
dont qui retire de la salle puis
également des citoyens qui s'organise
ensemble dans les ruelles vertes à
montréal dans d'autres villes de plus en
plus on voit qu'ils pensent we had
vertement oui enlevé de la salle puis
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire dans ces lieux
là début de rencontre de l'ue de
voisinage ben ça peut être venir des
lieux conviviaux des lieux de rencontre
des lieux d'agriculture urbaine des
lieux calme des lieux de voisinage de
regard dans le vague la stat on crée
aussi des milieux de vie dans nos villes
[Musique]